what do you got for me rough stuff i
noticed that when i started doing my
work online with the gaming community i
was judged a lot and that kind of
judgment basically brought me down into
the one thousand digitization by a
thousand sessions yeah i got fat i ended
up getting sciatica and then my wife
ended up leaving me so i started
watching your videos i started utilizing
those tools in real life recently i
decided to pursue a friend of mine's
co-worker and i use like sterling's tips
and i was like hey you know i put my leg
up against her when we were having a
good conversation then we go out to the
bar and then she's just kissing up all
on me you can't judge darkness without
light right
right the burden of performance is on
men to manage that relationship you
can't defer well what do you want to eat
tonight i don't know what do you want to
eat it's like that goes nowhere
fast so it's like we're going to get
this get in the car wear the black dress
that i like it's time for dinner right
like that's what women want and that's
truthfully what men want to be